Okay, so I've written down
a sort of flow chart here.
>> Okay.
>> An alternative for King Solomon,
that I'm going to claim better than
what King Solomon actually did
in the story which is threaten
to cut the baby in half.
>> It's certainly more complicated and
sort of.
>> Well, you think it is but
maybe it's not.
>> [LAUGH]
>> So I'm going to read all this to you
and we'll just kind of go through it and
you'll see if you understand.
Now, remember we're starting out
under the assumption that the value
of the baby to the real mother
is bigger than the value of
the baby to the fake mother.
>> Okay.
>> Okay, now here's step 0.
>> And again value here is
like willingness to pay.
>> Yes.
>> But we're just going to go with that.
>> Yeah, we're going to go with that.
So here's step 0.
King Solomon is going to choose a fine.
>> Okay.
>> We'll call it F.
That's greater than 0 but
meant to be small.
Okay.
>> So, you know something like a dollar.
Now what I mean by small?
I don't just mean something like
a dollar, I mean F needs to be
greater than zero, so there needs
to be some cost to this fine.
>> Mm-hm.
>> But it should be smaller than either
of the values v real or v fake.
Okay so B real bigger than
be fake bigger than F.
>> That's exactly right.
>> Okay.
>> All right, so
King Solomon picks the [INAUDIBLE] and
by the way tells the two women this
entire process that I'm I'm going
to another this is a surprise.
They both know this is what they're
going to have to go through.
>> Okay.
>> So King Solomon pick some value F.
Then in step one King Solomon
asks A is this your child?
If they says no then B gets
the child if A says yes
then King Solomon then turns to B and
says Is this your child?
If B says no then a gets the child
if B says yes, then King Solomon.
>> So somebody lying at that point
someone is lying King Solomon's not
having any of it and
tells a that a will pay F.
>> Wow, okay.
>> Okay.
>> And then, requires that
be an ounce of the value v.
Some number V that is
greater than F okay.
>> Okay.
>> Then the next step
King Solomon turns back to A and
he says.
[LAUGH] How about now?
>> Yeah.
How about now?
Is this your child?
And if A says no it's not my child then
B gets the baby, but has to pay $V.
>> Okay.
>> If A says yes then
a gets to keep the baby.
A have to pay V, and B has to pay F.
>> Okay.
>> I'm going to claim
that this is better and then claim
here and then cut the baby in half.
>> At least in the listening
true preferences.
>> Interesting.
That make sense.
>> It's intriguing.
>> Well, so.
>> I mean this still feels,
this feels weirdly asymmetrical.
>> Well, it is in some sense
asymmetrical
>> But
that's because there are underlying
values are asymmetrical.
>> No,
I mean the end of the day either A or
B got the baby with no fines
if somebody fessed up early.
If they make it past the you
guys are arguing stage
three then one possibility
is a pays A fine.
And B pays V and gets the baby the other
possibility is that A pays the fine.
And A pays V, and
A gets the baby, and B pays F.
>> Now after King Solomon tells
A they're going to pay the fine.
If we get down to here,
A instead pays V and B pays F.
So A doesn't pay F+V.
One of them is going to pay half and
one of them's going to pay.
>> Okay,k that feels more
symmetrical in short.
Okay, good.
Okay, so
how would you convince yourself of the
veracity of what I'm suggesting, that
this will do a better job of eliciting
true preferences of the mothers?
>> I guess I would think through
what the different, I don't know,
like, ways the game
can play out might be.
>> Okay, cool.
So we're going to go
under the assumption so.
Let's see one of these mothers is
really one of these mothers is fake.
So I mean I suppose it's
possible that they're both fake.
>> Let's not go.
>> Yeah, let's let's not go that's not
that's not allowed one of them is real
one of them is fake because this is King
Solomon and King and Knight shone like.